You've learned so much, drawing, view
port management, movement, user input.
And now it's time to build
a real game from scratch.
Icicles is a game where the player
first selects a difficulty.
And then can use the arrow keys or
phone accelerometer
to move their character left and
right to dodge the falling icicles.
This seems pretty easy.
So we can tap the screen again
to go back to the difficulty,
select screen and
select a harder difficulty.
Wow, okay, that's a lot of icicles,
oh, oh, no.
Oh, this is a lot harder.
So you can start building your own games
once you're done with this course.
Well, start this level using
the LBGTX project setup
utility to create
a totally fresh project.
Let's go.